[Musique]
on est en vie des pilotes de course
professionnelle quand même finalement
après c'est la branche pour un taux plus
proche de la course et d'être mécanicien
dans la course et c'est donc cette
branche que miguel a choisi à 29 ans il
réalise en quelque sorte un rêve
d'enfant il semblerait qu'il soit tombé
dans le réservoir
tout petit je suis venu chez signature
visiter pour j'étais tout petit avec mon
père est vraiment si le traité un peu le
lot envie de faire ça prend du coup j'ai
fait les études après en fonction on
arrivé là et je suis arrivé en stage
chez signature en 2009 et depuis je suis
toujours là mécanicien au sein des
tueries
l'avis de la quinzaine des mécanos se
partage entre la base à bourges et les
quatre coins de la planète du japon à la
chine en passant par les etats unis sans
oublier la course d course des 24 heures
du mans que signatech alpine gagnera en
2016 et 2018
120 jours loin de chez eux entre les
courses miguel ce qu'il de la logistique
durant le championnat son poste d un
rôle clé de la compétition précision et
rapidité
c'est la fameuse chorégraphie c'est à
dire qu'en trente secondes aujourd'hui
on sait changer quatre roues et
peut-être toutes les carrosseries de la
voiture si vous voulez pas les blocs
avant bloc arrière de la carrosserie
[Musique]
mais quoi
pour un mécanicien de course faire du
pit stop coincé c'est un peu l'apogée
sur les vêtements de miguel le à
d'alpine pour ce jeune berrichon est
comme une récompense une reconnaissance
on en tient une fierté qu'on a tous
connu les alpine bon c'est pas forcément
notre génération mais de courir à
l'effigié d'une marque au vent nuit
c'est sûr que ça apporte apprises
pendant quoi signatech se développe mais
pour la plupart des mécanos en
préparation de l'a36 il collabore au
montage des à 110 coop et gt4 une
nouvelle branche de la compétition pour
eux mais aussi la même exigence pensé à
tout à nouveau encore et encore et
surtout ne jamais oublier que dans la
voiture une vie est entre leurs mains
[Musique]